>>Heath Row: Thank you for coming to Authors
at Google today.
My name is Heath Row.
And I'm here to introduce Bonnie Schneider.
Bonnie is a meteorologist appearing on various
media platforms, including CNN and HLN.
She's also an author of a new non-fiction
book, "Extreme Weather," which you should
have copies of.
Bonnie is the on-camera extreme weather expert
and co-executive producer of a new special
on the DIY Network called "Last House Standing,"
premiering at the end of March.
Produced by Tara Productions, it's a one-hour
special that shows homeowners everything they
need to know about being proactive to protect
their homes from hurricane-force winds, torrential
rains, and devastating earthquakes.
Being in Southern California, hopefully we'll
learn a little bit today about mudslides,
wildfires, and the Santa Ana winds.
Ladies and gentlemen, Bonnie Schneider.
[applause]
>>Bonnie Schneider: Thank you all so much
for having me.
It is such a pleasure to be here at Google
and to be in California.
I was just here a month ago to shoot this
special, "Last House Standing," for DIY.
We went to Northridge, the site of a major
earthquake in 1994, and recapped what happened
and retrofit some homes.
So, I look forward to sharing that special
with you.
I have a handout on it on the DIY Network
on March 30th.
Well, without further ado, I wanna get to
my book, "Extreme Weather," which really was
an amazing experience for me to write.
And I'm so excited that the book is finally
out.
It seemed like it took forever to get it all
together--to get it written and on the shelves.
And now, it's here.
So, this book is a survival guide to all types
of extreme weather.
Here in California, a lot of people outside
of California, think you guys have perfect
weather all the time, but you, as residents,
you know that's not the case.
There's quite a bit of extreme weather in
the State of California.
And through the research of this book, I actually
spoke to many experts in California as well
as storm survivors in California.
You can see my book covers many topics, including
flash floods, tornadoes, hurricanes, wildfire,
heat waves, snowstorms, tsunamis, all types
of natural disasters.
And specifically for two of the chapters,
I spoke to storm survivors here in California.
And the first one was the land slide chapter.
And some of you may remember the devastating
land slide that occurred in La Conchita, California,
in 2005.
People were killed.
It was a real tragedy.
It was in January, so right around this time
of year.
One of the women I interviewed was a young
woman--18 years old--and she was staying in
La Conchita because she was in school in Santa
Barbara.
And she was heading to class.
The winter semester had just begun.
They just finished the Christmas break.
And it had been raining for days, but she
still wanted to get a head start and head
out to school.
So, she got on the road heading from La Conchita
to Santa Barbara, only to find mud flow ahead
of her and behind her.
Eventually, they shut down the highway.
And while it was inconvenient, she figured
that was really the worst of it.
Officials came and told her she had to leave
her car on the road.
And she did, along with many other residents.
And they took them back to town.
And she decided she'd just sit it out and
go back to her house.
So, she goes to the upper level of her house,
which was where the living room was.
And just when she picked up her cell phone
to make a call, she noticed that a side of
the wall was buckling in.
And something told her this wasn't an earthquake
because it wasn't a shaking motion.
It wasn't happening on both sides of the house.
It was just one side of the house.
So, instinctively, she grabbed her phone and
started to dart down the stairs to exit the
house.
And just then, she felt dirt coming on top
of her face and hitting her in the eye.
And that's all she remembers.
The entire house collapsed around her.
And just by sheer luck, she was on that staircase.
So the staircase, the way she fell, acted
as a barrier.
And along with a bookcase that collapsed just
at the top of her, but not on her, it gave
her a triangle area where she could breathe
and survive this devastating landslide.
Unbeknownst to her, there was a neighbor of
hers who was heading in the other direction
on the highway when the mud flow closed it.
He was heading home from work, He was an ER
nurse, returning from Santa Barbara to La
Conchita.
And he had done an overnight shift.
And instead of going home to bed, he got on
his bicycle and decided he's gonna look around
the neighborhood and see what's going on.
Well, sure enough, he saw-.
First, he heard that popping sound of the
landslide.
And then, he saw it, the whole hill side crushing
down on the town and on homes.
So he got on his bicycle and he started just,
he got off where he thought was the worst
of the area.
And he just called out, "I'm here to help.
Can I help you?"
And he heard muffled cries of not just Nicole,
the young woman who was trapped, but many
people.
So, he just listened to where he could hear
the loudest sound and just dug with his hands.
And he managed to find Nicole and rescue her.
And she had a bad gash on her leg, but she
survived.
And miraculously, these two were reunited
again.
And Bill, the man who found Nicole, was invited
to her wedding about a year or two later.
And her grandmother grabbed his hands and
just said, "You saved our daughter's life."
And I have stories like this throughout the
book at the beginning of every chapter of
"Extreme Weather," people that I've interviewed
directly.
Some of the stories you've never heard before.
Some are exclusive to the book.
But this book isn't just about survivor stories,
even though every chapter has one.
It really gets into practical, how-to advice
because I think all of us can agree that extreme
weather can happen at any time to any one
in any circumstance.
And this was just a young woman going to school
and she got caught up in almost a tragedy
of loss of life.
But she survived.
So many of the people that I interviewed were
on their way to work or to school or on a
vacation when this extreme weather struck.
So, it was my goal with this book to provide
readers with the information they would need
to be proactive to prepare for extreme weather.
And that means not only preparing, but also
giving practical advice of what to do if you're
in your car and the road floods, what to do
if you're on foot during a snow storm, or
how to react in you're in an office building
and there's an earthquake, which can happen
right here where we are.
So, the book "Extreme Weather" talks a lot
about those scenarios, including tornadoes.
[plays video clip]
>>Male #1: Oh, my God.
[wind noise]
>>Female #1: Oh, my God.
Don't even get by the balcony.
>>Female #2: Ya think?
>>Female #1: Ya think?
>>Male #1: It looks like it's going that way.
>>Female #1: [ ] Oh, my God.
>>Male #1: Dude, look at all the trees.
>>Female #2: You have to [ ] now.
[end clip]
>>Bonnie Schneider: What you just looked at,
that was actually footage of the beginning
of what was coming into Tuscaloosa, Alabama
just this past year.
Tornado season has been tremendously difficult
across the South, Midwest, much of the country
in 2011.
Five hundred and fifty two people lost their
lives in tornadoes.
That's record-breaking numbers for April and
for May.
And this one in Tuscaloosa was an EF-5 tornado,
which means winds greater than 200 miles per
hour.
Another EF-5 we all heard about last year
was in Joplin, Missouri.
So, tornadoes are one example of extreme weather,
but I think it's important to show because
everybody thinks it's gonna happen to someone
else.
[plays video clip]
>>Boy #1: I looked at my dad and he goes,
"Buddy, it's gonna hit us."
And I'm just staring at him.
I'm like, "No, it can't hit us."
And he goes, "It's gonna hit us.
We have to go downstairs now."
[end clip]
>>Bonnie Schneider: So, the question is, how
do you prepare whether it's a flash flood,
a hurricane, a tornado, a snow storm, wild
fire?
There's so many different types of natural
disasters that happen across the country.
And not only do we wanna protect ourselves,
but we also wanna protect our family and our
pets.
The woman that you see in the picture in the
corner of the screen holding the cat, that's
Mary.
And Mary is someone I interviewed in the early
stages of this book.
Actually, when I was writing the book proposal
a couple years ago.
And she's a Hurricane Katrina survivor that
I found on Facebook and contacted her that
way.
And she said to me, when I sent her an email,
"I found you on a survivor page of Hurricane
Katrina."
And I reached out to her that I was writing
this book.
And her message back to me was, "If you are
indeed the real Bonnie Schneider, I will talk
to you.
If you're some kind of imposter, I won't."
[laughs] I was thinking, "Of course I'm me."
But she turned out to have an incredible story.
I just scratched the surface from what I read
about her comments on Katrina.
This woman was separated from her beloved
pets during Katrina, like many people were.
And you'll read in the book what happened.
I don't wanna give away the story.
But it's an incredible story of what happens
when you're in that dire circumstance of having
to evacuate with very little notice and you
have animals to take care of.
So, that's something that I talk a lot about
in "Extreme Weather."
In fact, every chapter of this book features
advice on how to care for your pet as well
as your family.
So, even if you're looking at the wild fire
chapter, I interviewed an animal expert here
in California who treated animals injured
in wild fire and has practical tips for that.
So, each chapter is specific to whatever your
interest is.
And you're, maybe you're traveling to Florida
or to the Gulf Coast during the summer season
and you're interested in learning about hurricane
preparation.
There's that information for you as well if
you travel.
So, a lot about what I talk about is how to
prepare.
And you could do a lot to prepare before the
storm hits or before the disaster hits.
And one of those ways, and I think the main
thing you'll find I echo throughout the book,
is to have a NOAA Weather Radio.
Does anyone have one of these already at home?
That's actually a pretty good number because
most of time when I ask that question, no
hands go up.
So, that's great.
A NOAA Weather Radio is a special kind of
radio.
It doesn't mean it's necessarily very expensive.
You can get some for under 30 dollars.
But what this radio does is it's tuned in
to a special frequency from NOAA and the National
Weather Service.
And this way, you can get these updated watches
and warnings for your area.
One of the reasons these radios are so important--and
some of them have hand cranks.
If you lose power you wanna make sure they're
battery operated because you can't rely on
electricity.
You might lose it during a storm.
But the most important feature, I think, that
these radios have is they have an alarm mode.
So, if your area is under a tornado watch
or you're under any kind of weather advisory
and you go to bed and you're wondering, "Well,
what happens if the storm hits and we're all
asleep?"
This radio will wake up and it alerts you
that your county is under a warning.
And it will give you the information you need
if you needed to evacuate or to seek shelter,
for example.
So, this is something that every family should
have.
And another reason you should have it is because
so many of us go on vacation or we go away
for the weekend.
And the last thing we're thinking about is
how the forecast is gonna be because you just
wanna get out and get out and enjoy your vacation.
Well, some of the people that I interviewed,
especially on national campgrounds, said that
that's a huge problem that people don't check
the forecast before they go.
And they set up camp and they're susceptible
to lightening or to flash floods and things
like that.
So, just knowing what the weather is and keeping
track of it before you head out and while
you're away is so important because many of
these situations, I found in my research,
could be avoided.
Of course, sometimes they can't, but if you
can do anything to be proactive, it's important
that you do that.
Now, during the time of a storm, many of us
might find ourselves at home, stuck.
I know in Atlanta, Georgia last year, Atlanta
is a city that typically doesn't see a lot
of snow.
So when it snows, the whole city shuts down.
And for us, in January of 2011, we had a snow
and ice storm and I'll never forget it because
we didn't have power, some of us for a week
or two.
Imagine that.
And not only do you not have power, but the
roads are covered with ice 'cause there's
not enough snow plows.
So, you can be homebound in these situations.
And it can happen here in California as well.
So, you may have heard have your food supplies
and your water supplies.
But I give more information in the book that's
very specific.
How much food should you have?
For how many people?
What if you have pets?
How do you calculate that?
What about prescription drugs if you have
that?
Or, someone who has special needs in your
home.
How do you take care of them as well?
So, I'll give specific advice, a checklist
on these emergency supplies--it's one of the
final chapters of the book--that you can take
with you and see, do you have everything you
need at home?
What do we need to buy?
And it's just, this way it's peace of mind
that you have everything.
And I just wanna point out something that
may seem obvious, but you'd be surprised that
sometimes it isn't.
If you keep a lot of canned goods, make sure
you have one of these--a manual can opener.
Because if you lose power and you're using
the electric can opener, you're gonna really
wanna get to your supplies then you won't--.
So, that's something very important to remember.
Now, sometimes a disaster happens and we're
not homebound.
We have to get out.
Now, this was really evident to me in the
wildfire chapter I did.
I interviewed quite a few firefighters and
captains here in Los Angeles, Los Angeles
County Fire Department.
I talked to people in Malibu, who had been
through extreme fires in 2007 and they were
evacuated.
And they really told me what it was like to
have that knock at the door and say, "OK,
you have to leave now."
Or, "you have ten minutes."
What do you do?
So, this picture actually is from Hurricane
Rita in 2005.
And this is outside of Houston, Texas.
So, this is what it could look like on the
highway when everyone's trying to get out.
You can even see some people just gave up
and pulled to the side of the road.
So, you wanna make sure that your family has
a disaster plan.
And there's a lot of different factors that
go into that in terms of making sure everyone
in the family knows what their role is if
you had to evacuate.
Does everyone know where you'd meet in the
house?
How to reach each other?
If you all have cell phone numbers, make sure
it's all grouped together for friends and
family so quickly, you can reach each other.
And another thing, I mentioned earlier about
pets.
And this is really key because again, this
could really be a big concern.
If you have a pet and you wanna take it to
a shelter, make sure you have the proper carrier
because some people will come up to a shelter
with a cardboard box full of kittens and they
won't take you.
So, you have to have the proper carrier.
And you're probably wondering, "Well, I could
have the carrier, but my dog or cat is stubborn
and they won't get in it."
There are tips in the book on how to teach
your animal how to be more comfortable in
a storm situation.
A lot of dogs, for example, are frightened
during thunderstorms.
And that sound of the thunder really frightens
them, or the flash of lightening.
So, I have some tips on how to keep everybody
calm and evacuate in a orderly way.
And in terms of reaching everyone, and this
is something everyone here at Google is probably
even more familiar with than most of the people,
is how do you use social media in a natural
disaster emergency?
During last year's tsunami and earthquake
in Japan, in March of 2011, we saw incredible
use of Twitter and Facebook and all sorts
of social media to communicate because a lot
of people couldn't communicate with their
cell phones.
So, how do you use social media in a weather
emergency.
Well, the first thing you wanna do is make
sure that you know how to use social media
and not wait till the disaster hits.
And I give some practical advice as well as
tips on who to follow on Twitter and maybe
some things that you didn't already know--free
information that's available to you--because
you wanna make sure that even if you're working
here at Google, you might be the most technologically
savvy person in your family, make sure everyone
in your family can use, can upload photos
and communicate possibly with a geolocation
tool so you can find each other.
Because often in a disaster, I mentioned the
wildfire knock at the door, that could happen
when parents are at work, kids are at school,
someone's at a friend's house.
And that's why social media can really come
in handy and help you.
And I think that that's a really unique chapter
to the book.
And I'm happy that we were able to include
that in there.
So, the book really is a survival guide.
And it's really a tool that you can consult.
Read it once.
It has a lot of bullet points, so it's a pretty
easy read, but it's something you can go back
to.
And if you're traveling, you can take a quick
glance.
For example, I know that we can be threatened
by tsunami, here on the West Coast.
And just recently, there was a tsunami warning
actually along, up and down the West Coast.
But for many, you don't encounter tsunami
unless maybe you're traveling or you don't
think about it, for example.
And in the tsunami survivor I interviewed
for this book, I have to tell you, that story,
even as I was writing it, I was glued to my
computer because it's so incredible that this
man survived.
He was on vacation in Phuket, Thailand in
2004 when that tsunami hit.
And he literally saw the sea pull back, far,
far back, so it was as if he saw the bottom
of the ocean.
Imagine what that would look like, that site.
And how disconcerting it is to look out and
expect to see the sea, but you see sand and
little puddles of water with fish popping
up.
So, he saw the water recede and pull back
before the horrible waves of the tsunami came
in and killed so many there.
So, his first person account that I'm able
to tell in this book is really riveting because
he's from California.
And he worked overseas and that's where he
was vacationing over the Christmas holiday.
So, he found himself on vacation having to
seek higher ground in this tsunami, something
he didn't really grow up understanding or
knowing what to do.
So, knowing about these different phenomenon,
well, you may not think it applies to you
right now.
You may find some day you'll be somewhere
and it's good to know.
So, I really wanted to get all this information
out to everyone in a really concise and easy
way.
As a meteorologist, I had the experience of
talking about these events when they're happening
in breaking news and that situation.
But I find what really is on my mind is that
I really, if I can do anything to help people
prepare and have them feel more empowered
and less frightened, frankly, of extreme weather,
then that's really what I'm setting out to
do with this book.
I can remember I had just started at CNN in
2005 and it was the summertime and I was so
excited to be working there.
And a month later, Katrina hit.
And I was only on the air a couple months.
And I remember driving.
It was ten o'clock at night and my job was,
they said to me, "You're gonna cover overnights--midnight
to four AM."
And I thought, "OK.
That sounds good."
So, the weather advisory for Katrina that
we were getting from the National Hurricane
Center from the local National Weather Service
along the Gulf Coast, it was so dire and the
language was so--.
It's so indelible in your mind.
You can't forget how serious the warnings
were.
I mean, we remembered that at the time.
So, I was driving to work and I was holding
onto the steering wheel.
And I remember I was thinking like, "Is everyone,
do people realize how serious this is?"
Because people can get very complacent.
If a hurricane doesn't hit year after year,
then they say, "Oh, it's gonna happen to someone
else."
Like you saw on that video when that young
boy said, "Well, it's not gonna hit our house."
So, that was really the beginning of the idea
for this book for me, is that I wanted to
be able to get that information out.
For example, in a tornado, you may know that
the best place to be is a safe room in your
house--a closet, a bathroom, or a basement.
But I also give you some other tips.
For example, if you're driving or you find
yourself in an open area, I just wanna try
to cover all bases of where you could possibly
be when extreme weather hits.
So, that's a little bit about my book.
And it was really something I'd been working
on for a long time.
And I'm really delighted to share all with
you.
And that's a little review I got from Kirkus.
That was the first review I got.
So, and that's what I was happy with that
review for many reasons, but one is that it's
a lightweight book and I wanted people to
be able to tote it with them when they travel
and keep it in their car or give as a gift
to someone, just so you can show that you
care and you want your family to stay safe.
So, that's a little bit about my book.
I just wanna mention also, you can see that
the forward is written by Max Mayfield.
You may have heard of Max.
He was the former director of the National
Hurricane Center.
During Katrina, he was on television all the
time back then.
And Max really is a legend for all of us meteorologists.
And he is really incredible too, I've had
the opportunity to interview him on CNN.
And so, for him to write this forward was
a real honor for me and it's a privilege.
And I hope you all read it because he really
really knows firsthand what can happen during
the worst case scenario when you're prepared
and when you're not prepared.
And he's been around a lot longer than me,
so he can really give you that firsthand information
right at the top of the book.
So, that's a little bit about the book, "Extreme
Weather."
And I thank you so much for having me here.
I'd really love to hear your questions specific
to anything you have here in California or
anywhere in the country.
Yes.
>>Female #1: For us here in California, you're
in a workplace.
Can you outline for us the best places to,
how we should evacuate or you should stay
within the building?
I know a lot of people have a tendency to
try to leave the building immediately when
there's debris and that sort of stuff.
>>Bonnie Schneider: Yeah.
And that's actually true because in the research
I did for the earthquake chapter, I found
that people do rush out of buildings.
And that's sometimes how some of the worst
injuries occur because debris can be falling
off a building.
Really the best advice that I received for
the earthquake chapter is to drop, cover,
and hold on.
Wherever you are, get under a desk and hold
on.
The earthquake itself won't last usually that
long, but you wanna stay under something that
can protect you from debris.
With the risk of running out of the building,
you're risking getting hit by something on
your way out.
Obviously, you wanna stay away from any windows
and that's true of any extreme weather events.
And whether you're at the workplace or whether
you're at a hotel on vacation or you're at
a friend's house, always be aware of where
the exits are and how you could get out.
For example, in the tsunami chapter, I talk
a lot about being aware of how to reach higher
ground.
And that's also true if you're camping because
people find themselves in areas that can flood
and you could be in a tent or that sort of
situation.
So, you wanna know all the escape routes and
the way to evacuate quickly.
Does anyone else have a question?
>>Female #2: I was gonna ask about the worst
natural disaster that you've seen.
>>Bonnie Schneider: I would probably say--.
I recently, for the DIY's special, I had the
opportunity to go to Tuscaloosa just a month
ago.
And remember, that tornado hit last year in
April.
So, here it is, almost a year later, and you
can still see the exterior of a building completely
gone and all the damage.
And it's amazing.
I mean, I don't think I would have believed
it if I didn't see it in person.
And I'm seeing it after a lot of the area's
been cleaned up.
So, seeing the devastation of a tornado, I
think, has a real impression on me.
But reporting even from the studio and talking
about all these different disasters also stayed
with me.
And I've had the opportunity to talk about
everything on the air that's in the book.
I haven't seen everything personally, but
I've had a chance to at least explore reporting
on it.
And through the book, interviewing people
who were there.
Does an--?
>>Female #3: Question here.
What do you think is kind of the biggest disaster
waiting to happen?
>>Bonnie Schneider: That's a good question.
I think it really depends on where you are.
I think that 2011 was an epic year for extreme
weather.
We had 14 natural disasters, costing billions
of dollars for the country.
The worst of it, more than half of the people
that were killed were killed in tornadoes.
So, I do think that because of the growth
of the population and the development of where
people are living, more people will be impacted
by extreme weather.
So, it really depends on where you are in
terms of what could be the worst situation.
And we're seeing a lot of stuff that people
have said to me and I use Alabama as an example
when I was just there.
We don't see these big tornadoes in Alabama.
They think, "Well, this is something you'd
see in Oklahoma."
Well, this type of extreme weather can happen.
And it can be devastating.
I mean, here in California, just about every
year, we have the fire season where we're
talking about homes being evacuated.
And sometimes, you're talking about tens of
thousands of people having to leave their
home.
So, it depends on where you are and how you're
impacted.
Last year also, we had record drought and
fire in Texas for example, and the heat that
persisted there.
It was incredible.
Last year we had so many days where we had
consecutive triple digit days in Dallas for
example.
Record-breaking heat even in Newark, New Jersey.
So, the extremes are definitely happening
all over, wherever you are.
I haven't gone to any place yet--I've been
traveling a little bit for this book--that
hasn't had something where they have that
perfect weather.
Any other questions?
>>Female #3: I'm quite interested in tsunamis
actually.
>>Bonnie Schneider: OK.
>>Female #3: Obviously two massive tsunami's
within in the last ten years.
And I just moved to this neighborhood and
you see the tsunami warning signs, evacuation
signs, around here.
Do you know much about how prepared we are
in Venice?
Like, for instance, my house had to have tsunami
coverage, on my insurance for my house.
Do you know about--?
>>Bonnie Schneider: I'm not sure about the
specific city is prepared, but the fact that
you know that you're in an area at risk for
tsunami is really half the battle.
A lot of the interviews I've done for this
book, people didn't know they were in an area
where a landslide could occur or a tsunami
could occur.
So, tsunami warnings have improved and they
especially improved after 2004.
So, we can be more prepared and seek higher
ground.
And you're right.
We've had two huge tsunami events related,
of course, to two massive earthquakes immediately
preceding them.
So, the risk is there.
And it's important that you know that even
here in the US because I think until Japan
hit, and then we had that advisory and warning
we had on the West Coast--.
Remember that camera that was poised watching
Hawaii and we're all waiting to see what happened?
I mean, I think that really woke people up
that this could happen in the US.
Anybody in the back?
[laughs] Any questions?
No.
OK.
Well, thank you so much for having me.
I hope you enjoyed the lecture and I hope
you enjoy the book.
OK, thank you.
Thank you.
[applause]